So far you've covered supervised and
unsupervised learning.
There's a third major school of
thought in machine learning,
called reinforcement learning.
Reinforcement learning is inspired
in part by the behaviorist school of
thought in psychology.
And it's a way of tweaking our
system to prefer being right or
wrong in certain ways.
And so a good way to think about this is
with an example, think of a smart cab,
a self driving car.
It's learning how to navigate roads,
it's learning how to transport its
passengers and it knows that there's
different ways it can get optimal.
It can be optimal if it gets there
in the shortest amount of time.
It can also be optimal if it
gets there without crashing.
But really we would want it to
prefer one of those definitions of
the optimality way above the other one.
We would much prefer it get there
much later than it would otherwise,
than to actually get in
an accident on the way.
We really want it to prefer
not getting in an accident,
to just getting there
as fast as possible.
So, reinforcement learning would
be a way of teaching the system to
prioritize in that way.
We attach rewards and
punishments to different outcomes.
And by weighting those rewards and
punishments in the right way,
we can teach at the right level of
priority to assign to different goals.
So in this case,
we would assign a much bigger
punishment to getting an accident,
to just being a couple of minutes later
than they could have been otherwise.
So in this unit, we'll talk about
reinforcement learning, and
how augmenting the machine learning
process with these rewards and
punishments, can really
fundamentally change the system's
understanding that we generate.